may 23 1934 it's just another beautiful
spring morning in louisiana on the
surface everything seems as quiet and
calm as always but in the background
trouble is brewing on a highway near the
small town of salis a group of police
officers live waiting for two of
america's most wanted criminals they
were preparing for an ambush to catch
america's favorite partners in crime
bonnie and clyde
the story of bonnie and clyde is insane
they were these armed robbers and
murderers that were practically escape
artists they had invaded the police
dozens of times traveling across the
country robbing people while capturing
the hearts and minds of america so if
the police wanted this ambush to be a
success they would have to take them by
surprise
just two days earlier the cops at cod
were that the pair was heading to the
house of an old family friend iverson
methane here was their chance to trap
the couple when they least expected it
this was the best chance they had come
across in over two years so this time
they had to get it right so the cops
came up with a simple plan they
convinced bonnie and clad's family
friend meffin to loan them his car the
cops then parked the car on the side of
the road the same road that they knew
bonnie and clyde would be taking that
morning and hopefully seeing their
friend's car on the side of the road
would be enough to make them slow down
just enough and that is when the cops
would strike
everything went just as planned the cops
parked the car on the side of the road
while six police officers hid nearby and
just as they had hoped bonnie and clyde
came driving down the road as they got
closer they noticed the parked car up
ahead recognizing it clyde slows down
and looks out the window and that was
all the cops needed within seconds the
cops unloaded their guns into bonnie and
clad's car it sounded like a complete
war zone in the middle of louisiana and
in the end bonnie and clyde's car was
hit by around 130 bullets in total the
couple died almost instantly bonnie was
still holding a half-eaten sandwich as
her body slumped out of the car door
both of them had their guns in hand but
they hadn't even had the chance to fire
back
for most criminals that would be the end
of it the news about their death would
fill the headlines for about a week and
soon after that their knees would be
forgotten but not bonnie and clyde the
moment everyone heard that they had been
killed crowds rushed to see their
bullet-filled bodies it was a spectacle
a mob of people literally chasing after
a bullet-torn car with two corpses still
in it the crowd got so desperate so
chaotic that people even started cutting
off pieces of their hair and ripping out
bits of their clothes to take home as
souvenirs someone even tried to cut off
clyde's ear as a souvenir it was madness
these were murderers after all but no
one seemed to care that they had spent
years robbing banks stealing cars or
that they had killed at least 13 people
thousands of people attended their
funerals and mourn their deaths and
today almost 100 years after being shot
to death we're still talking about them
movies music books tv shows youtube
videos i mean even their bullet written
card is still a major attraction in las
vegas that you can go see right now all
of this was because bonnie and clyde
tapped into something special it was the
height of the great depression at the
time when one out of every four people
were unemployed and people were
desperately looking for something to
look up to enter bonnie and clyde the
romantic rebellious couple taking their
lives and careers into their own hands
and even though today everyone has
pretty much heard of the name bonnie and
clyde the real story of bonnie and clyde
is even crazier than you think my name
is jake tran i make documentaries on
money power war and crime of my team
subscribe for more if you want to win a
thousand dollars cash you just have to
be following me at jake trin and you're
automatically entered a few of you have
won already watch out for fake accounts
i will never message you asking for
money and this is bonnie and clyde
america's infamous partners in crime
[Music]
[Music]
we might be a far cry away from the
great depression today but the financial
system today is still pretty messed up i
mean look at how backwards the process
of getting a loan is today we all need
loans so that we can make big purchases
like houses and cars but you can't get a
loan unless you have good credits but in
order to build good credit you need a
credit card but to get a credit card you
need good credits are you seeing the
problem here
this whole chicken and egg thing used to
be a big problem but thankfully now we
have extra extra is the future of
building credits because it's the
world's very first debit card that helps
you build your credits yes you heard
that right a debit card that actually
helps you build your credits you can
even earn reward points and everything
just like a real credit card but without
the credit checks interest and the risk
of burying yourself in debts and extra
is already changing the lives of over
125 thousand people and counting here's
how it works first you go to extra.apps
jam with the link below you sign up for
extra and link your bank account and
then you'll get your extra card in the
mail now whenever you pay for something
simply swipe your extra card just like
you would any other card and extra would
then cover the purchase they would then
auto pay themselves back the next
business day and at the end of the month
every purchase that you make will be
reported back to the credit bureaus as
credit worthy purchases building up your
credit with everything you buy and
you'll get all of this without having to
make a deposit or go through any credit
checks this is something that i really
wish i had when i was first trying to
build my credit so i'm really proud to
promote extra so if you want the easiest
way to start working on your credit
right now pause the video and go to
extra.app jake tran with the link below
that's extra absolute jake tran with the
link below thanks to extra for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
[Music]
before the crime spree before the
shootouts before the infamy there was
just bonnie parker and clyde barrow
bonnie and clyde both had pretty tragic
backstories bonnie was born in 1910 and
lived in rowena texas with her parents
older brother and younger sister her
life was fairly well to do until her
father passed away when she was only
four years old faced with no other
choice the family moved to a
poverty-stricken neighborhood in dallas
called cement city to live with bonnie's
grandparents even though she had a rough
start bonnie was still seen as a good
girl she was a smart student who earned
honors and she was particularly
interested in poetry and literature a
passion that would continue even during
her criminal career
bonnie loved music and performing on
stage she even participated in school
pageants and sang broadway hits at
talent shows bonnie loved movies and
would often tell her friends they would
see her name in lights one day
only about an hour away from bonnie's
home in cement city a young clyde barrow
was growing up but he didn't have nearly
as nice of a reputation
clyde was born in toleko texas a little
over a year before bonnie he was the
fifth of seven siblings born to a very
poor almost destitute family of farmers
they were so strapped for cash that the
family spent a few months living in a
wagon and then later a tent when clyde
was 12 they gave up on farming and moved
to west dallas where his dad opened a
gas station like bonnie clyde also loved
music from an early age he taught
himself how to play the saxophone and
guitar but he didn't have the good
grades or promising future that bonnie
did from the very beginning he was your
typical bad boy thanks mostly to the
influence of his big brother buck the
brothers started out with small crimes
petty theft and things like that but
soon they dropped out of school and
found their criminal forte grand theft
auto and armed robbery
in 1926 at the age of just 17
clyde was arrested for the first time at
the same time an almost 16 year old
bonnie was preparing to get married to
one of her classmates a guy named ray
thornton and it wasn't long before they
both dropped out of school and got
married
but looking back it seems bonnie had a
thing for bad boys
her new husband roy was almost never at
home and just over a year after getting
married he was arrested for robbery and
sentenced to five years in prison bonnie
and roy never actually got divorced but
they never spoke or saw each other again
either down on her luck bonnie ended up
moving in with her grandmother and got a
part-time job as a waitress to support
herself she would write in her diary
about how lonely and sick of her life
she was she craved something more
something better and so did clyde but
just as they were making their way into
adulthood and hoping life would get
easier on its own all their best
intentions and biggest dreams came
crashing down around them it was the
beginning of the great depression and
the beginning of bonnie and clyde's
infamous partnership
the great depression took its toll on
america pretty quickly in the wake of
one of the country's most turbulent
financial crisis bonnie lost her job
waitressing and life was looking worse
than ever and that's when it happened
19 year old bonnie was hanging out at
her friend's house in west allis when 21
year old clyde barrow walked in
it was love at first sight
bonnie and clyde bonded over their
shared ambitions more than anything they
both create fame and something more than
the poor low class lives they were
destined to live but given clyde's
criminal streak their relationship would
have to jump some hurdles first only a
few weeks after they met clyde was
arrested on multiple counts of car theft
and robbery he was sentenced to two
years at eastland prison farm but unlike
her husband bonnie thought clyde was
worth waiting for and not even prison
could stop their romance in fact bonnie
looked at it as just another challenge
to overcome and the best way to do that
was obviously to break clyde out of
prison so during one of her visits
bonnie managed to smuggle a gun to clyde
back then prisons weren't exactly
high-tech buildings with cameras and
guards on every floor an eastham prison
farm where klay was being held looked
like nothing more than a really big farm
so a gun was more than enough help for
clyde to escape and even got a few
prisoners out with him unfortunately it
only took a week before they were
recaptured this time an extra 14 years
of hard labor was added onto his
sentence but instead of breaking his
spirit this only made clyde more
desperate to get out of prison
during his time at eastham he was
starved abused by guards and allegedly
assaulted by other inmates
clyde was just about to try his most
daring escape plan yet when his mother
worked out a deal with a judge and
somehow got him out on parole he was
free
here was his chance to get back on the
straight and narrow
there was just one problem
when clyde got out of prison he was
absolutely sure of just three things he
was in love with bonnie parker he was
nowhere near the end of his crime spree
and he would rather die than go back to
prison
it didn't take clyde long to return to
his old ways like most people sent to
jail he came out a more hardened
criminal than he went in there weren't
exactly a lot of job options for an
ex-jailbird during the great depression
and clyde figured that by robbing and
stealing he was just taking what he
deserved but the government owed him for
letting him rot in jail but this time he
was going to be more calculated
he started putting together a group of
thieves and criminals that would
eventually become known as the baro gang
and bonnie was by his side the entire
time he couldn't bear to be without her
so he brought her along this was the
start of their robbery spree they were
having a grand old time robbing gas
stations and small stores to make ends
meet until april 1932 when one of their
robberies went wrong clyde managed to
escape but bonnie was caught and put in
jail for two months but in typical 1930s
fashion when a grand jury deliberated
her case they came to the conclusion
that a woman would never participate in
a crime voluntarily obviously she had
been forced by the gang
so she was released and immediately went
running right back to clyde and let's be
honest no one really cared about bonnie
and clyde when all they were doing was
running around stealing things and
holding up tiny stores but that all
changed in the summer of 1932. clyde and
one of his gang associates were in
oklahoma when they were approached by a
sheriff and his deputy without any
warning clyde and his friends started
shooting the sheriff was killed the
deputy was injured and clydeberry was
officially a cop killer this was a much
bigger deal to law enforcement and it
marks the beginning of bonnie and
clyde's life on the run over the next
two years they became famous for evading
arrest every time they managed to get
away from the police by the skin of
their teeth it only made them more well
known
by the following year bonnie and clyde
were starting to become household names
in april of 1933 cops found out about an
apartment where the gang had been hiding
they surrounded the place and a shootout
went down but even with all the bullets
flying around clyde just dove through
the garage door past the cops and
escaped
inside the apartment the cops found a
bunch of bonnie's poems and rolls of
undeveloped film
pictures and words that would go on to
be famous for nearly a century
this new evidence told a compelling
story two criminals in love fighting
against the world police quickly slapped
their photos on the couple's wanted
posters in the hopes that more people
will recognize them but that only made
them more famous than ever
suddenly the image of clyde being a
ruthless gang leader and bonnie as a
cigar-smoking gun-wielding sidekick was
front-page news and people loved it it
was cool and sexy and totally different
from most people's reality during the
great depression even if they were
committing crimes and killing people
america was entertained bonnie and clyde
were the great depressions robin hood
figures stealing money from the man
giving the system the middle finger
although they never gave any money back
to the poor but for bonnie and clyde the
high was never meant to last
[Music]
bonnie and clyde didn't mind killing
people if they had to but they didn't
like murdering just for the sake of it
it was more like if they didn't shoot
their way out they would end up in jail
or dead
and that just wasn't an option
but they weren't naive to the reality
that their spree was unsustainable long
term quite the opposite in fact in one
of her poems bonnie wrote quote they
don't think they're too smart or
desperate they know the law always wins
they've been shot at before but they do
not ignore that death is the wages of
sin end quote
quote someday they'll go down together
and they'll bury them side by side to a
few it'll be grief to the law a relief
but it's death for bonnie and clyde end
quote it was like she had a glimpse into
the future
the only thing bonnie got wrong was that
they weren't buried together against
their wishes on that fateful day when
the couple was ambushed on their way to
their friend's house when everyone
pushed and shoved to get a glimpse of
their corpses they were surprised they
didn't see two scary hardened criminals
bonnie wasn't even five feet tall and
clyde barely weighed more than 125
pounds they were small unassuming normal
looking people and that's the thing
about bonnie and clyde most of their
glamorous criminal story was just that a
story
even the photos that had gone 1930s
viral at the time were later believed to
be all an act the couple was amused by
america's perception of them and took
the photos to poke fun at their gangster
image bonnie didn't smoke cigars and
clyde was thinking of ending their crime
spree long before cops ended it for them
the truth was neither of them liked life
on the run
it was hard dirty and depressing they
spent days on end driving around and
sleeping in shifts trying not to be
caught they ate sardines from the can
because they couldn't afford much else
they bathed in rivers and rarely if ever
felt comfortable to top it all off the
pair wasn't even very good at stealing
money they never got more than fifteen
hundred dollars from their robberies and
sometimes only got away with as little
as eighty dollars but that's not the
type of story that sells papers and so
even after they died the story of bonnie
and clyde lived on the couple achieved
the fame that they had hoped for it just
wasn't in the way they thought
[Music]
even though bonnie and clyde died in a
shootout they got off pretty easy
compared to some of america's targets i
mean look at the cia's black site
program the cia basically used secret
prisons to detain people they thought
were enemies of the state
and many of the men and women who ended
up there were totally innocent
but that didn't stop the cia from
arresting them on suspicion black
bagging them to secret locations around
the world and putting them through some
of the most gruesome enhanced
interrogations that you could possibly
imagine all without ever charging them
with a crime
the things that cia officers would do to
prisoners in black sites are sicker than
anything we've ever discussed on this
channel before but we know a video that
goes into cia black sites their enhanced
interrogation styles and why they're
probably still happening right now would
get demonetized by youtube in a
heartbeat so that's why we've released
it as a full-length private documentary
that's only available to members of this
channel all you have to do to get access
to this exclusive documentary right now
along with other feature-length videos
we've already published like mkultra
monsanto efri jepstein and roots of
terror in the middle east is click that
join button below people willingly give
universities tens of thousands of
dollars without them ever teaching you
about how the world really works but
when you become a member you'll get
access to all this insider info for only
five dollars a month and there's a
refund policy too unlike most youtube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund scroll down and click that join
button right now
[Applause]
what's up guys hope you guys enjoyed the
video and if you're new here my name is
jake and this is one of the biggest
channels on youtube for documentaries on
money power war and crime we make
multiple videos just like this one every
single week for free so make sure you
click that subscribe button below if you
want shorter versions of these videos
you can follow me on facebook and for
just the 1 thousand dollars you can
follow me on instagram at jaketram but
that's going to wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you